oh this is stunning hey everyone and
welcome to our guide to need for speed
payback brought to you by EA I'm Dan Mar
and I'm joined again by Yanni now this
time we've finished the street leagues
and now we've opened up another one of
the core missions which means we're
going to experience more of the
cinematic action that this game is known
for so what are you looking forward to
here there's a height I saw that comes
straight up it's gonna be very very
movie like I'm really excited for this
one good stuff let's check it out so
target right these enforcers going down
this Mustang is heavy GE oh look at that
flip go here we go what happened
[Applause]
but once that wasn't my fault Oh No whoa
trail of destruction this is ridiculous
that's fantastic oh this is amazing
that is amazing that's I was acting
purely on instant then what's got two
more enforces here he's not our last
long come on yes
how nice is that I like the behavior of
notice what the AI is really designed to
not just let me give you a hard time but
for it to look impressive all they're
doing so you know the way they sort of
flank you either side when you're trying
to catch up to the truck here we go here
we go here we go
what's gonna happen now
and she goes this is where Jess comes in
this is what we like to see if this
really is playing out like a Hollywood
actually this is crazy
I love the fact that we've done this
sort of Street leagues which is more the
sort of traditional racing that needs
speed is known for yeah and now we're
getting into this of nuts action cherry
what's going on
do I get to play this now that's a
mentored afternoon I take it back to the
airfield look at the speed of this the
difference is aerodynamics it alone
absolutely insane it's like a bullet
I'd like to pretend that was slightly
intense that that section towards the
end I think that was where my reflexes
took over because I was not processing
how fast that car was going down that
stretch of highway sitting here watching
it it was rapid and I came to see you
weaving in out of cars nitrous kicking
in without a doubt the fastest car we've
seen so far so far but um yeah that's
just a small taster of some of the epic
moments you're going to be seeing in
Need for Speed payback and we've got
plenty more of the game to show you in
future videos yani thank you so much
again for joining me thank you for
watching and we'll see you next time